hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast social housing of
laboratory rabbits and presented by
Sarah Thurston a social housing
coordinator at university of michigan
i'm susie valdez elaborate and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
which is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of the screen type the
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble - seeing or hearing this
presentation please click on the help
desk located on the promotional board at
the bottom center of your screen or use
that ask a question box and let us know
if you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and does
offers continuing education credits
click on the accreditation button
located on the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen please join
me now in welcoming our presenter Sarah
Thurston and will now turn the
presentation over to her welcome Sarah
thank you Susie thank you everyone for
coming today hello my name is Sarah
Thurston and like Susie said I'm the
social housing coordinator at the
University of Michigan today I'm going
to be discussing our extensive social
housing program with laboratory rabbits
we have an average yearly census of
around 400 rabbits at a time
and because of this we have faced an
trouble shot many challenges with the
social housing of such a large
population of animals so for today's
presentation I'm going to focus on
answering some of the most common
questions that arise regarding the
social housing of rabbits so these
include how do their wild counterparts
live so for this we're
look in the natural history of our New
Zealand white rabbits why are we
socially housing rabbits for this we're
going to look at the regulations as well
as the rabbit preferences the social
housing actually good for the rabbits
for this we're going to look at the
benefits of social housing as well as
the detriments of social isolation and
then how do we create new pairs for this
we'll go through our methods of pair
creation as a part of that what behavior
should I monitor for so we're going to
go through our atha gram that we've
developed in the behaviors that you're
going to want to look through as a part
of that and then how do I maintain these
rabbit pairs once I've created them so
for this we'll go through some methods
for pair maintenance and then lastly
what do we know if I can't socially
house my rabbits so for this we're going
to go through some alternative methods
to social housing so before we begin I
would like to offer the disclaimer that
I will only be discussing New Zealand
white rabbits today because that is what
the majority of our very large colony
consists of we do also also pair house
Dutch belted rabbits here and we pair
and maintain them utilizing the same
methods that I will be presenting here
today however we just don't have high
enough numbers that we can really
confidently recommend the methods in
regards to those but we have had good
success with it so far but today when I
say rabbit I'm going to be describing
New Zealand white rabbits exclusively
okay so to answer the first question of
how do their wild counterparts live
we're going to look at the natural
history of the New Zealand white rabbit
so the rabbits that are most abundant in
North America are going to be cotton
tails and around us here in Michigan we
mostly only see the eastern cottontail
the simple I guess for Dennis this
causes a lot of confusion for people
because they will sometimes ask why are
we trying to socially house our
laboratory rabbits when the rabbits that
live in my backyard are solitary I never
see them with a
rabbits so the main answer to this
question is that they are not the same
rabbit the eastern cottontail is what we
are going to see in our backyards
however the European rabbits which are
the ancestors of our New Zealand whites
are social species so to look at the
natural history or kind of comparing
these to the stumble itis are the ones
that we're going to see in our backyards
these are a solitary rabbit they're
territorial and they're not going to
burl however the original Angus which
are the European rabbits and the
ancestors of our New Zealand white these
are social species they live in warrens
of about six to twelve adults and they
do burl they create these very complex
underground burrows with lots of
entrances and I and European rabbits can
live in distinct social groups of up to
four males and up to six females so this
shows that the natural history of the
New Zealand white is as a social species
so here's a picture of a European rabbit
warren in england in which you can see
multiple rabbits living within a social
group you can see an entrance to that
underground burrow that they've dug this
is not what you're going to see in your
backyard with the eastern cottontail
that were accustomed to seeing so you
can see where some of the confusion
comes in sometimes with people and then
while it's important to know how our
laboratory rabbits wild counterparts
live it's also really valuable to know
whether these behaviors have been
conserved when we brought them into a
laboratory setting so there's been some
great research to show that domesticated
rabbits do bring retain their social
behavior behavioral repertoire of the
Royal ancestors this is shown by the
amount of time that the rabbits choose
to spend in body contact with another
rabbit between 65% and 80% of the time
they chose to be in body contact and
that's the same for deaths between
domestic and wild rabbits so this shows
that that social behavior that they
exhibit in the wild is conserved when we
bring them into a laboratory setting as
well so the next question that we're
going to try to answer is why are we
socially housing grass
and this answer has a two-fold answer
this question has a two-fold answer
we're going to be looking at the
regulations as well as the rabbit
preferences so there's three main
regulatory guidelines that provide
oversight to rabbits social housing so
these are going to be the 2011 guide for
the care and use of laboratory animals a
lack international and the office of
laboratory animal welfare or a la the
2011 guide basis single housing of a
social species should be the exception
it also goes on to say that single
housing should be justified based on
experimental requirements or veterinary
related concerns and simple housing
should be reviewed on a regular basis by
the iaccoca and a veterinarian Amick
also has a position statement on social
housing in which they state that social
housing will be considered the default
method of housing for a social species
if they're not socially housed it must
be justified based on one of the
following criteria either social and
compatibility veterinary concerns or a
scientific necessity and social holic
housing policies and single housing
exceptions should be reviewed regularly
by the iacocca
and the veterinarians which goes along
with exactly what the guide states as
well and then going along with this olá
has you know very similar regulations
and they also describe a little more
about the justifications that allow for
singly housing so there's three main
justifications that a situation can fall
into to allow a socially housed species
to be singly housed you can provide
scientific justification so this would
be a situation where for example you
need to measure water consumption in
individual animals and social halloween
would be incompatible with that research
study so this is anything that could
affect the research that's being done by
social housing veterinary concerns for
animal welfare is also justified this
could be a situation where you maybe
have an older dog with arthritis or who
needs some special medicine or
treatments and having him full-time so
house with other kind of specific dogs
might lead to injury or something along
those lines so veterinary concern is
also justifiable and then the last
justification is social and
compatibility and so this could be a
situation such as you have a colony of
sexually mature male rabbits so they are
not socially compatible to be housed
together this would be justified
according to Ola and then in addition to
the regulatory guidelines regarding
social housing we also socially held
based on the rabbits preference so there
was this really great study done that
provided preference testing to female
New Zealand white rabbits and they show
that they worked almost as hard for
social contact as they did for food so
as you can see in the diagram they place
the rabbit in the home cage and there
were doors that they had to push through
to get to either a cage with food an
empty cage platform cage that had a
little bit of more of a enriched cave
setup or social cage that provided them
a small mesh panel in which they could
have limited interaction with an
unfamiliar rabbit and they found that
she would work almost equally as hard to
have that social access as she would to
get to food so this shows the incredibly
high value that rabbits themselves plays
on social interaction with conspecifics
so other studies done have kind of shown
similar results finding that when given
the choice new zealand white females
would form small social groups ranging
from one to three conspecifics with
browse rabbits spending about 88% of
their time in close proximity so this is
a really high percentage again showing
that they really value the social
contact so the next questions that were
found to answer is whether central
housing is actually good for rabbits so
to answer this we're going to look at
some of the benefits of social housing
and then we're also going to look at the
flip side of this to look at some of the
detriments of social isolation so there
are lots and lots of documented benefits
of social housing for social species
um just I've listed just a few here
social housing provides buffering from
stress social isolation of rodents has
resulted in increased aggression and
hyper responsiveness to stressors social
housing is the ideal enrichment it's an
ever-changing interactive stimuli that
they can constantly find enriching in
human novel ways group housing can
reduce anxiety boredom and frustration
which is obviously something that we
don't want to see in any of our
laboratory species especially when
they're in like a smaller cage setting
these things can be really problematic
so group housing as a way to reduce
these behaviors and social housing also
encourages active behavior so it
increases physical fitness so there's
less risk of self-injury to the back and
legs and it can also reduce gastric
stasis and then social housing also
normalizes physiological values such as
circadian rhythms which can be extremely
valuable to investigators when they have
their entire colony on kind of the same
cycle so just the benefits of social
housing are well documented so are the
detriments of social isolation once
again these are just a few examples of
some of the detriments of social
isolation but they can be very severe
social actually less social isolation
can interfere with brain and behavioral
development it can increase oxidative
stress it can increase heart rates cause
how your white blood cell counts at a
higher chance of disease progression it
can increase time spent in abnormal
behaviors and it increases the time that
they spend in active so these are all
things that we really don't want to see
in our lab species for their overall
welfare so social isolation is the most
easily observed in the development of
these chronic stress behaviors or
stereotyped use the ways that these tend
to manifest in our rabbits are improper
grooming so we'll see
urine spraying on themselves urine
staining they can not room sometimes
get real like matted and icky they're
not taking care of themselves or they
can do the opposite and excessively
groom to the point where they have fur
flaking or over barbering which can lead
to lesions we'll see them sometimes
pacing or circling as a result of these
sometimes you'll see metal chewing so
they'll chew on the bars or you can see
them licking or chewing and the licks it
or feeders so different metal parts of
their cage sometimes we'll see excessive
scratching or digging at the cage floor
and we also notice sometimes odd
interactions with humans so these are
going to be behaviors that are not
typical rabbit behaviors that are seen
when they normally interact with their
caretakers so things like lunging and
growling at their caretakers or
excessively stomping when they come in
the room so we treat all of these things
as symptoms of chronic stress so to
really understand a social housing is
good for gravity we first really need to
understand rabbits themselves a much
research has been done in the past few
years to understand the very complex
nature of rabbit social behavior for
most of their time at the laboratory
species rabbits retreated and housed
basically as large mice it hasn't been
until the past few years when we finally
started to get a more complete
understanding of their social
complexities that we realize that
they're actually much more similar to
small primates in terms of behavior they
have incredibly complex social
hierarchies which are similar to
primates and they should be provided
with the same behavioral monitoring as
primate colonies are provided with so in
order to understand these complex
behavioral relationships we needed to
create a behavioral eat the gram and
sense rabbits our prey species they
often behave differently when there's a
human observer in the room so to
circumvent this we set up
high-definition cameras to record
several hours of normal pair
interactions when no humans were in the
room
this allowed the rabbits to express
their uninterrupted species-typical
behaviors so we then watched all these
videos and scored all these videos and
we'll go through the ether grin later in
the presentation to go through what we
found and kind of what each of those
individual
behaviors mean okay so now that we
understand the routes our social species
who should be housed accordingly we need
to determine how to actually create new
pairs so to do this I'll go through our
methods of pair creation before we get
started however I do have a few overall
disclaimers firstly do not attempt to
start pairing rabbits without the proper
approval from the principal investigator
as well as the veterinary staff at your
institution proper training on species
typical behavior is crucial to the
success of this program so make sure to
do your research and get all the
necessary approvals prior to starting a
pairing program trained staff is
essential to this process
rabbits creating and maintaining their
dominance hierarchies can look extremely
volatile and it is vital that the people
in charge of these pairings are aware of
the differences between normal behaviors
and abnormal behaviors next all of our
rabbits are closely monitored at every
stage of the pairing process by trained
husbandry and veterinary staff inferior
later we'll talk about a minor wounding
that does not result in pair separation
but we just want to make it clear that
even though the worms are categorized as
minor and we don't separate for them
they are still under full veterinary
supervision at all times and then the
next disclaimer is that for the next
little while I'm going to be talking
about methods to create new unrelated
pairs these newly created pairs are all
females we do have a very large pair
housed male collie but they are all
sibling males who are methods of
maintenance are the same for the male's
however our methods of creation that
I'll be talking about today
apply just to females we don't pair any
unrelated male rabbits okay and then
just one final disclaimer at the
University of Michigan all of our pair
house privates are housed in
caging so they're housed in a
double-wide cage with a divider removed
so today when I'm going to be describing
our pairing process and our maintenance
in our whole system this is going to
apply to rabbits that are paired in
cages and not through piles
it's better in a pen setting or floor
setting so to actually start creating
your pairs or several things you need to
do prior to pairing first you want to
get your cage set up so you're going to
have a clean neutral double wide cage
with the divider removed and you want it
to contain at least two of everything
anytime we're doing pairing we want to
make sure that we're doing everything we
can to decrease any resource competition
or resource guarding so we make sure and
give them at least two of everything so
they can share if they want but they
don't have to if they don't want to so
make sure that you're providing a
minimum of two hiding or scape
opportunities this can be a hut a shelf
a box or something they can hide in you
want to provide a minimum of one
enrichment item per rabbit and one
destructible item per rabbit you're
going to provide them with two separate
piles of pay and two separate feeders
and access points for water so as you go
through the pairing and pair monitoring
process it's good to keep in mind that
pair should always have two of
everything just to make sure that we're
not encouraging any sort of resource
competition okay so the day before
you're going to start pairing you're
going to want to collect urine from a
male rabbit within the colony it's
possible you want to use a male from the
same room that the females are going to
be housed in and you want to make sure
that you mark the females with urine
from the same male in wild colonies the
dominant buffle urinate on the rabbits
of his breeding group descent mark them
- um he's going to send mark the rabbits
in his social group which indicates to
them that they don't need to compete
aggressively so to try to translate this
into a lab setting we collect urine from
a male rabbit to do this we overturn the
liner underneath the cage so that the
plastic side is facing out and the urine
will collect on top of the liner so you
can see there that urine collecting on
top of the liner plastic side facing up
and then you're just going to syringe
off the urine oh sorry my pictures
didn't come up there anyway you're just
going to syringe off the urine from the
top of the liner there and store it in a
sterile conical tube
okay so also prior to Pickering you're
going to ensure that the rabbits can be
individually identified I do have one
final disclaimer we are having some
technical problems so there was intended
to be quite a few videos in my
presentation that will unfortunately not
be able to be shown today so anytime you
see a big blank spot on my screen I
didn't just forget to fill it in there
was a video there that's not going to be
able to be shown unfortunately at the
end I will give you information on where
you can find those videos if you want to
see them in other places and I will try
to describe them as best as I can but I
do apologize that you see these gaps
that's where a video would have been but
that's okay so just know that I didn't
forget to put things in my presentation
okay so primary make sure that you can
ensure that rabbits can be individually
identified this is going to allow you to
accurately track the behaviors that are
displayed by each rabbit to get an
understanding of their dominance
hierarchy so you're going to want to use
a blue or a purple non-toxic marker
that's animal safe to mark the tips of
their ears we make sure you use blue or
purple because we've tried red and
orange and obviously they can be
confused for bodily fluids and that can
cause all kinds of problems so we found
blue to be the best and also if you mark
the tips of the ears this seems to be
the best spot because you can see it
really clearly from anywhere across the
room and also it's harder for them to
groom it off so it tends to stay on
longer okay so the last step before
placing the females together is to mark
each female with that pre collective
urine so you're going to want to add a
generous amount of urine to a cotton
ball or a gauze pad and place it on the
rabbits forehead and in between her ears
after marking each with urine add the
animals to the neutral cage together
make sure you add them pretty closely
together no more than a couple minutes
in between each to prevent any one
animal establishing the cage as its
territory there's just a nice video here
of wiping urine onto a rabbits forehead
which is exactly how that
so once you put them together and then
you're going to start your monitoring
process you want to monitor them
continuously for at least 60 minutes so
if you see continuous chasing by both
rabbits so we're going to call this
circling if you see any biting or clear
fighting behaviors which will be
jousting or lunging if you see any of
those you're going to intervene with a
spray of water from the water bottle and
then Mark additional locations such as
their back face or rear with urine the
water should never be used as a
punishment tool we use it merely as a
distraction they usually just take like
one squirt and they're going to stop
what they're doing move to their
opposite sides they don't like to be wet
so typically if you just give them that
little squirt in the back they'll go to
their opposite side and groom the water
off of themselves and it's usually
enough to distress them from the
aggressive behavior so during this
initial pairing process you're going to
document every behavior that you see on
the ether gram so this includes signs of
aggression submission dominance stressed
behaviors normal behaviors anything that
you see is going to be put on to the
fifa gram with the corresponding times
that you saw it we do this for a minimum
the first hour and the reason for that
is because the majority of the
aggressive interactions are seen during
that first hour
however if after that first hour you
feel uncomfortable leaving them you can
increase the monitoring time at your own
discretion every pair is a little bit
different so you really want to you know
use your own discretion with this so
during that first hour you're typically
going to see a wide range of behaviors
some of the most commonly seen behaviors
in that first hour other than your
normal driving behaviors like eating
drinking laying down are going to be
mounting chasing nipping and fur locks
you'll probably see quite a bit of
little furballs fly as they're you know
figuring out in this first initial
process and that's normal
if clear fighting behavior does develop
this is when you're going to interrupt
with a spray from the water bottle or if
that doesn't
work your going to manually separate
them tree plant stick gloves because
their nails are very sharp and you will
get injured it is really important in
this initial stage to not intervene too
quickly it's very hard for us to
overcome that sensation because when we
see them doing this behavior we
initially want to separate them you
don't want them to get injured however
this is how they work out their
dominance hierarchy this is a very
normal thing for them and when we
intervene too quickly we can disrupt
that hierarchy establishment process and
they can be unable to determine it if we
just keep intervening so we don't want
to intervene too quickly it's really
important and it's really hard to train
ourselves in that because that's
instinctually we want to jump in but
it's very important to not intervene
right away so there many signs that a
pair is establishing a successful versus
a non successful social introduction
some successful indicators are clear
dominance and submissive behaviors
affiliative behaviors such as grooming
eating or drinking resting side-by-side
these are obviously very positive things
there are also some signs that you are
having an unsuccessful introduction this
can be both rabbits engaging and
dominance behaviors does indicate that
you have two dominant rabbits which is
obviously not going to be a successful
player if you see any resource guarding
it's not a great sign and then of course
if you see any wounding this is you know
a real indicator of an unsuccessful
introduction and wounding is observed at
any time
contact the veterinary staff right away
but we don't separate the pair unless
the wounds are to the genitals or the
eyes or there's active bleeding or like
a deep lesion that you think might need
a suture those are the only reasons that
you're going to separate if you just see
a small lesion we're going to leave this
pair together and work through it but
you're still always going to report it
to the veterinary staff any wounding so
if after that first hour they're resting
and eating peacefully they've
discontinued any chasing and they're
showing successful indicators of hearing
you can go ahead and leave
you're going to conduct two additional
ten-minute checks throughout the rest of
the day and if that pair continues to be
stable after both of your additional
checks you can leave them together
overnight so that first morning after
cohousing it's also a little
nerve-racking or you know that first
morning you're always very nervous
especially when you begin but just in
our experience we've done this quite a
bit we very very very rarely find
lootings
that next morning so you're going to be
nervous but it will be okay that next
morning though you want to make sure and
examine animals for wounds so that you
want to physically touch them to make
sure you're feeling under the fur for
any scabs you might have missed make
sure you check the genitals
once again separate if you find any
wounding to the genitals or eyes any
deep or actively lesions absolutely
you're going to separate right away any
lesions at all or any wounding you're
going to contact the veterinary staff
I'm going to say that a lot to make sure
that it's very reiterated when we
separate what types of wounding but make
sure that for any wounding you contact
your veterinary staff so once a pair has
successfully completed overnight
cohousing
without any evidence of serious routine
and the pair is demonstrating compatible
behaviors they are considered a stable
pair you're going to document this on
that rabbit social introduction log and
you're going to generate an interaction
and enrichment log stable beer should be
monitored at least once daily for ten
minutes for the next week
an additional enrichment can be placed
if you feel it's necessary okay so now
we will go through the behaviors that we
use to create our ethogram so you're
going to monitor for these behaviors
during pairing and all throughout the
life of the pair these are positive
neutral negative and communication
interactions we're going to go through
each behavior individually and this I
apologize again this is where we have
videos showing all of these behaviors we
will not be able to show those today so
I will try and explain it as best as I
can but I'm not a rabbit so it's going
to be a little hard to understand some
of these I will show you
then where you can give these videos
okay so first time we're going to go
through the positive behaviors
since rabbits have such a structured
dominance hierarchy there always needs
to be a clear dominant and a clear
submissive rabbit so you really want to
see signs indicating that you have a
dominant in a submissive so in this
particular video what we saw was there
was a submissive eating at the feeder
and the dominant came over and he wasn't
aggressive or forceful he just kind of
made his presence known and the
submissive moved away so the dominant
could eat from that feeder in that
relationship you can clearly see who's
dominant and who's submissive there's no
fighting there's no aggression it's just
a clear hierarchy relationship so this
is what we want to see if you seem
sharing resources this is a great sign
usually what we see in our rabbits is
they tend to eat all their food together
out of one feeder and then they'll go to
the other side and eat all the food
together out of the other feeder so this
is a really positive sign they're
choosing to share their resources
even though remember they have to have
everything so they don't have to share
if they don't want to they're choosing
to share so this is a really positive
thing in time with the allo grooming
this is very positive so this is going
to be when one rabbit is grooming the
other rabbit we typically see the
dominant grooming the submissive but not
always sometimes it does go the other
way and that does not seem to indicate
any sort of hair breakdown
it's just each pair seems to be a little
bit different but when you see this this
is a very positive sign and then we also
consider self-grooming
to be a very positive sign because when
they're in that space together if a
rabbit felt really threatened by her
partner she's not going to take the time
to groom herself and put herself in a
vulnerable position especially when they
you'll see I'm grew and they kind of go
up on their back legs and they expose
their bellies they're putting themselves
in a very vulnerable position if she
felt threatened by her partner she
wouldn't do that
so have you seen them self grooming near
each other this is a really positive
sign that they feel safe and secure
within that relationship with their
partner
if you seem sharing space
obviously a great sign they have two
full-size cages so if they don't want to
they don't have to be anywhere near each
other so when they choose to be together
and choose to share space this is a
really good sign and I'm really bummed
about this video because this video
happened to show two adult males that
were almost two years old and they're
huge and they both choose to snuggle up
together on this one perch even though
they have the whole two cages they want
to snuggle together on us one perch and
they lay like that all the time so I
always like to show that video when
people say that you can't pair how adult
males because we have lots of examples
to prove otherwise
and those two old males are a really
good example of that so when you see him
cheering space this is a good thing any
interaction with the enrichment is great
if you see them interacting with it solo
this is positive they're having fun
they're utilizing their enrichment
they're using the enrichment for
whatever they're supposed to be doing to
be expressing you know natural behaviors
this is great even better is when you
see him interacting with the enrichment
together this particular video showed
conceived me showed two rabbits that
were interacting with an enrichment
device together and they're not fighting
over it they weren't you know try and
take it from each other there was no
aggression they were just choosing to
play with it together even though they
have to they don't have to share they
were doing it together they were tearing
apart of I think it was like tube that
was stuffed with hay and toys and things
so they're choosing to interact together
with the enrichment so this is a really
great time so the next category
behaviors are neutral behaviors and
these are exactly what they sound like
when you're red but they're not
interacting at all so you can see in
this cage they're as far apart as they
possibly can be one sleeping on one
perch one sleep and on the other perch
they're not interacting in any way this
can be totally fine and it can be just
normal behavior however if you are
monitoring a pair and every single day
they are consistently neutral all you
ever see your neutral behaviors you want
to keep a really really close eye on
this pair what this tends to indicate is
that they have not established their
dominance hierarchy and these are the
pairs that tend to lead to wounding so
once again I don't want to scare anybody
it can just be a pair that you don't see
interact and that's fine but if you
consistently only see neutral behaviors
and you never see any positive or
negative behaviors it's only neutral
just keep an extra close eye on this
pair and the next up we'll go through
the negative behaviors so for the
aggressive behaviors these are going to
be things like circling biting you know
obvious aggressive interactions for the
circling it's really important to note
what circling is and what circling is
not so circling is when both rabbits are
chasing each other in a circle like a
little you know tornado like they're
both going around each other in a circle
it is not one rabbit chasing and the
other rabbit fleeing away that's a
totally different behavior that we'll
talk about later this is both rabbits
continuously circling each other
trying to get at each other this is
aggressive this is something that you
want to intervene in with that spray of
water another behavior that's a little
bit more subtle but it's really really
important that your technicians are
trained to recognize her difficulty
establishing dominance so in this
particular video it looks like you have
a totally normal pair so you have a
dominant on top and and she's mounting
the submissive on the bottom and she's
doing some elbow grooming it looks
totally normal looks like he's got a
fine pair however is the video goes on
he will start to see the submissive turn
around and searching Nick at the
dominant she starts to kind of nip at
her face a little bit like she said she
looks like she's starting to get kind of
annoyed shirts kind of try and shake her
off a little bit eventually she turns
around and chases the dominant away this
shows that that submissive rabbit is not
submissive she does not want to be
submissive and this pair has not worked
they're dominant hierarchy they don't
know who's dominant they both clearly
want to be dominant typically these
pairs do not succeed so you want to be
really watchful for these kinds of
behaviors if you have to dominance and a
pair they're obviously not going to be
successful this was another video that
showed a similar situation where at
first it seemed like they were a
successful pair and then that kind of
broke down what was interesting about
this video though is the submissive
rabbit that was on the bottom she was
being mounted by the dominant she
struggles to get away when she runs away
she doesn't run to the other side of the
cage she's not afraid she's not hurt
she's not injured she turns around and
comes and gets back on top of the
dominant so the one that was submissive
she wants to be dominant so this again
is a clear sign that this is a pair that
has not established their dominance
hierarchy they don't know who's in
charge in this particular pair we did
have to separate them because they
couldn't figure it out so make sure that
people are trained in knowing what those
behaviors look like okay so these next
ones are kind of a gray area their
communication interactions so they're
all really normal natural behaviors that
rabbits use to communicate with each
other so that makes it kind of confusing
because they're normal behaviors for a
rabbit however when you put these pairs
in a lab setting where they have limited
space to flee away from each other these
communication behaviors can sometimes
turn into aggression if they're not
checked so because of that we do make
sure and intervene in these behaviors
even though they're not necessarily
negative behaviors so it's kind of
confusing we were finding that these are
the behaviors that people were
separating for the most so we want to
make it clear that we do not need to
separate for these behaviors these are
normal ways that rabbits communicate
their dominance hierarchy and they do
not need to be separated for these so
the first is a chase flea behavior which
I could show you the video because it
makes it a lot more clear the difference
between circling and chase flea but you
can visual
is it so the circling is where they're
going to be going at each other both of
them around the circle that's the
negative behavior a chase flea is where
you're going to have one chase and one
flee this is okay you can clearly see
when you watch that behavior who's the
dominant rabbit and who is the
submissive rabbit as long as one is
fleeing while one is chasing that's okay
in the wild some dominant rabbits
require an active submission from all
their submissives as often as every
single day so you might see this
behavior every day and this is just the
dominant reinforcing that he or she has
dominant and the submissive reinforcing
that he or she is submissive and so this
is okay we don't want to separate for
this behavior same with mounting like we
see in a lot of our other species the
very normal dominance behavior we do not
want to separate when we see this we see
a lot of urine marking in our male
rabbits but we also see it quite a bit
in our female rabbit so you can see in
the picture there's urine staining on
the shelf and on the cage and then also
in the rabbit itself on his nose and on
his face
this is pretty common it's just a way
that they're using to kind of mark who's
dominant and the submissive I think it's
more frustrating for the technicians
because as soon as they change the cage
the rabbits going to mark all over it
again to make sure that you know their
territory is known so they always get
kind of frustrated when they choose to
express themselves in this way but this
is a normal behavior we do not want to
separate for this and same with
barbering we don't separate other
species for barbering we don't want to
do it for rabbit you're typically going
to see barroom start on the nose in
between the ears and on the back of the
neck you just want to keep an eye on it
to make sure it doesn't progress to
where it might be a lesion or something
like that and then excessive thumping
this is kind of a hard one to explain
this is not when you go in a room and
one rabbit thumps and then they all dump
and they get excited this is not that or
when you pull off the food bin and they
all start something this is not that
this is totally different
this is a behavior a communication
behavior between the dominant and the
subordinate rabbit in this particular
video the dominant rabbit was staring at
the submissive rabbit down here I was
standing up tall
the submissive rabbit was laying down
low with her chin down and the dominant
rabbit was never breaking eye contact
with the submissive and just repeatedly
excessively thumping this is a very
clear intimidating dominance behavior
but this once again is a normal
communication behavior that we do not
want to separate for okay so now that
we've established how to create a pair
and what behaviors we need to be looking
for we're going to cover how to maintain
that so we do this by a three-step
approach enrichment intervention and
documentation and monitoring so the
first step is when any of those negative
behaviors or any of those blue
communication behaviors whenever we see
those we increase their overt rent to
Monday Wednesday Friday and then we're
going to document their observation
Monday Wednesday Friday so when I say
increase the Umbridge min to Monday
Wednesday Friday that means Monday
Wednesday Friday they're getting a new
enrichment item each of those days and
then if your progresses to the second
step this is if those aforementioned
behaviors get worse or if you know any
new behaviors you're going to increase
that effort went to daily and document
observation of that pair daily and daily
means weekends holidays every single day
of the year this pair is going to get a
new and rich with two new enrichment
items and documented observation
hopefully those first two steps work and
you don't ever progress to step three
however if you do this would be when the
previous enrichment intervention did not
fully succeed and some aggression does
occur this is where you're going to
spray with water to distract monitor
closely for five to ten minutes and at
this point you need to put them on
enrichment and documented observation
daily just to reiterate this again if
any wounding occurs you need to notify
the veterinary staff immediately but do
not separate their we do not separate
the pair unless the wounding is on the
Jenna
the eyes there's a deep puncture or an
actively bleeding lesion to reiterate
that one last time these are the only
reasons that we immediately separate a
pair any genital wounding I won't be
actively bleeding lesion or deep
puncture something you think might need
a suture or something if we see a small
scratch or a scrape or you know a little
hair pull or you know scratch on the ear
these are typical things that we see on
lock with rabid carry we do not separate
for this these are the only reasons that
we immediately separate however we of
course do report on to veterinary staff
and they are under monitoring so the
second part of our maintenance plan is
enrichment intervention it is important
to note that you must get approval from
your enrichment committee veteran high
staff and your PI before you have any
new enrichment items are kind of just
standard baseline pay all rabbits
receive pay every single day no matter
what their social housing status is so
if they are singly housed pair house
pregnant lactating weanling anything no
matter what you get hey every single day
we do this because studies have shown
that hay is effective in reducing
abnormal behaviors and it should be
provided daily so we do for our
enrichment we found that rabbits get
bored extremely easily and so it's
really vital to rotate between different
groups to maintain novelty of enrichment
item otherwise it completely loses its
value for the rabbits so we have a few
different enrichment groups that we
rotate between we have low value high
value and supplemental enrichment we'll
go through those and then just as a side
note too we Auto place all of our
cardboard items prior to providing them
to the rabbits just to make sure that we
prevent them to prevent the spread of
any pathogens so our low value in
Richmond are going to be things that
they can easily manipulate around the
cage things like toys cardboard wood
black wood chew sticks things that
provide them value and that they enjoy
but it's not going to provide long-term
value you know they're going to get
bored with it
exactly so here I just had a couple
videos that showed the value of
cardboard it's one of our favorite
enrichment because it's free it's
usually sanitized Abul and it's quick
for the technician and the rabbits
actually love it so we just take the
liner boxes that the rabbit liners come
in we cut them into strips we autoclave
them roll it up and you can stick it
right in that cage doors and the rabbits
will take a while like trying to get it
into the cage and then once they get it
in there they'll scratch it dig it up
and make a big mess with it and just
have a great time so it's really quick
for the text and it takes the rabbits
awhile and it cost nothing so perfect
enrichment so our high valuable
high-value enrichment items are going to
be destructible any of you who have
spent time with rabbits know that they
love to destroy things so these are
going to be things like tubes stuffed
with hay or shredded paper boxes bags
all stuffed with things the stuff in the
treats toys all kinds of things if you
have rabbits that are you know k figured
it out a little too much you can
compound this you can stuff a tube
inside of a box stuff that stuff it
inside a bag you know get really
creative with it but they absolutely
love these destructible --zz now this
was a really cute video of some rabbits
just destroying some stuffed bags it's
definitely a favorite with the
technicians as well because it's
something that you can you can create
for them you can give it to them
you can immediately see them enjoying it
and having fun with it so it's really
positive for the staff and the rabbits
so our next time value enrichment item
is food treats which is obviously
high-value with pretty much any animal
in humans
we just want to make sure similar to
primates that we provide it in a way
that encourages them to have to engage
to get the treat so we try and provide
it either fresh frozen dry we'll try and
stimulate different senses sometimes
we'll you know freeze things and mash in
fresh fruit and then sprigle like dried
parsley on top or something just ways
that they can have to kind of work for
it or Forge or something
if you just hand them a carrot they're
going to like it but the value is going
to be a little lower than if they have
to work for something and then our last
groups of a recommend is supplemental
enrichment so these are things that are
never provided as the sole enrichment
item but are provided in addition to the
other enrichment items so these are
going to be things like instrumental
music a white noise machine with both of
these things we make sure that we put
them on timers so they're never on more
than eight hours a day at the absolute
maximum and we use grooming brushes too
when we have rabbits that are friendlier
or tend to enjoy it or when they're out
for a nail trim will kind of give them a
brush with the grooming brush to see how
they like it make sure you don't ever do
this up the rabbit if you're stressed by
it obviously and then just to really
quickly show how impactful this
enrichment can be this was a paired
female who had gotten in a fight with
her sister and you can see she's got
lesions on her ears she's got some
lesions and hair loss on her nose as
well so we put them under monitoring and
the only thing that we changed is we
increase their enrichment to Monday
Wednesday Friday that was the only
treatment by day 11 you can see both of
the lesions on her ears of heal and the
lesion on her nose is much smaller and
there's some hair growing back in and
then by day 14 sorry it was a video
again so it doesn't show up but I
promise it was completely healed her
ears were totally healed her nose was
totally healed and most of the hair had
actually started to grow back in and the
only thing we did was increased our
enrichment so it really really does make
a difference
in these guys lives it's very valuable
okay so the last part of our pair
maintenance plan is increased
documentation and monitoring of pairs
for each pair we monitor their aging
weeks using a vertical flag behind their
cage card this allows the room
technician to quickly be able to scan a
room and know which pairs are kind of in
that danger zone sexual maturity between
begins between weeks 12 to 17 we did an
internal study here and found that
around
of the negative interactions begin
between weeks 10 to 20 so we want to be
able to quickly visualize who is in that
10 to 20 weeks own so that we can kind
of provide a little extra monitoring and
care for that pair so every single pair
has their own social housed interaction
and enrichment log this log is used to
detail dovetail pairs history as well as
what enrichment has provided to the pair
and how they interact with that
enrichment each pair must be monitored
and documented for a minimum of one day
per week
for five to ten minutes and this is on
top of the daily observations that the
husbandry technician is already doing if
that bear this log is extremely valuable
for tracking the Evan flow of pairs
relationship problems start to arise we
can go back and kind of track their
behavior so it's really valuable to have
so utilizing the described methods over
a 12-month period we've maintained 172
rabbit pairs 62% of those were female
but 38% were males out of that only 8%
of total pairs had to be separated for
fighting and those are separated at an
average of 18 and a half weeks old so
they're right in that danger zone of the
10 to 20 weeks our oldest male pair was
75 weeks old or older the female pair
was 92 weeks old and both of them are
separated for lab reasons they had
nothing to do with their relationship
they weren't fighting anything like that
they had very positive relationships so
we do get a significant number of
actually very old rabbit pairs that are
still a really successful stable pair
okay so the last question we're going to
answer is what if I can't socially house
my rabbit so we all know that social
housing is the best method to house
social species like rabbits but what if
we can't socially house them so as you
learned when discussing the regulations
there are justified situations too when
you can't socially house and a lag is
come up book is really great graphic to
show that even if we can't provide
full-time social housing we still need
to look at the relative social
experience of the animal to see how weak
and stony its social needs the easiest
way that we found to do this is to drill
holes and the dividers so we drill five
about the size of a quarter in the
divider and this provides protected
access through the divider so this video
is another really cute one of two adult
males interacting through that divider
with the holes this is especially
important in the male's because once
they're separated they're separated
forever so that male is going to be
alone for the rest of his life so by
giving him these dividers with holes you
can still provide some sort of social
experience for him which is really
important on a study was actually done
in 2010 to determine if the male rabbits
actually prefer these social access
dividers so they had no paid portion so
they didn't have to see their partner if
they didn't want to and they had a clear
portion with a bunch of holes drilled
into it so they could have social
contact if they wanted but still in a
protected way so the cages were divided
and the rabbits were scored as either
spending time in the social quarter when
they chose to be by the clear divider
with the holes or when they were in
separate cages but spend time in the
section adjacent to another rabbit in a
supper cage and the results found that
the rabbits spent significantly more
time in the social quarter of the cages
with the perforated dividers these
rabbits also synched in their circadian
rhythms and we're more willing to
approach unfamiliar staff due to the
social buffering effect of having a
quote unquote cage mate so it really
provided a lot of value to these male
rabbits so another way to provide an
alternative social experience is to
provide part-time social housing so this
can be done by allowing rabbits to
interact even either in an open play pen
or a divided play pen so this way they
still get some exercise and interaction
and playtime but they're still divided
so they can't get injured or anything
like that so it's a way to really give
them some sort of protected social
contact and since rabbits are often
utilized in an antibody in antibiotic
production studies the question was
posed as to whether antibody production
would be affected
them have time in these play pens either
open or protected so an internal study
done here at the University of Michigan
found that the animals that were allowed
to have open play time did not have an
affected antibody production so just to
finish up here can I have a quick
programmatic thought this is an issue
that has come up multiple times when
we're dealing with rabbits social
housing it's the question of why do we
tolerate minor wounding and other social
species but we're not willing to inhabit
oftentimes the pigs and any PS and mice
will have small lesions associated with
social housing and institutions are
willing to accept this as part of the
fair housing process however when
rabbits show related minor wounding
they're usually separated immediately so
we just want to encourage everybody
who's socially housing rabbits or
thinking about socially housing rabbits
to manage your expectations and really
realize that social behavior may result
in minor cosmetic defects but the
benefits of social housing greatly
outweigh the negatives of isolation of a
social species who puts a lot of value
on social housing on so I have selected
references available here if you look at
them and I have tons of people to thank
I won't go through everybody but this is
a huge huge process as you can imagine
you need support from every single level
from you know bottom to the top and
everything in between and I am very
grateful that we have a wonderful team
here of all people from all different
areas of our facility who have really
put in a ton of time and effort and
energy into making our program a success
and this this is a huge undertaking and
can absolutely not be done by one or two
people you need to have a solid team so
I'm very grateful for all these people
so thank you very much for listening to
this my contact is here I'm always
willing to talk about rabbits if you
have any questions please contact me and
to think I have any questions tonight
thank you so much Sarah for that
informative presentation we will now
start a live Q&A portion of
this webinar if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type that question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click that Sun button well answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's take a look at our first incoming
questions from our audience members and
thank you so much for your participation
today our first question is what advice
would you give a facility trying to
start up a rabbit social housing program
great thank you for that question so the
advice that I would give a facility who
wanted to start a rabbit social housing
program I think the most important
advice is to do a lot of research
there's so much that goes into rabbits
social housing so much behavioral choose
you need to understand it's very similar
to if you were to start a primate social
housing program you really are going to
want to do your research to understand
what behaviors you're looking for and
what those behaviors are going to
indicate in terms of your parent process
I would also recommend making sure that
you have buy-in from everybody before
you start the process everybody who is
involved really needs to be fully on
board and committed to this process if
you have someone who's not fully
committed it can really make the process
a lot more difficult so it's really
important to from the husbandry
technician who's in the room every day
to the vet techs to the vas staff to the
attending veterinarian to the principal
investigator and their lab staff it's
really crucial that everybody
understands why you're doing this why
you want to socially help these rabbits
and that they understand the benefit of
social housing the detriments of social
isolation it's it's just absolutely
crucial that you have your whole team
really bought into this process because
it is such a team effort you're going to
need that support from the whole team so
those would be my biggest pieces of
advice if you want to start a program
Thank You Sara and what would you say
what are the resources that are
available to help troubleshoot rabbits
social housing programs yeah so some of
the resources are actually really new
because this is such a new thing that
we're all kind of trying to figure out
together so one thing that I would
recommend is we just wrote a paper for
Joel on this exact process and it is in
production and will be available as soon
as the video is completed being edited
it's really helpful because it goes
through step by step each step of the
pairing each behavior you're looking for
what it indicates and then we also
filmed a video tutorial to go along with
it
that shows you exactly what those
behaviors look for which is really
crucial because before you've seen these
rabbit interactions you can't really
understand what they look like until you
see them because they look horrifying
honestly they look terrible they look
like they're just killing each other but
then you separate them and check them
and there's no lesions and they're
completely fine
they're very dramatic so it's really
important for you to actually see this
ahead of time so you know not to panic
when you see it for the first time so I
would definitely recommend checking out
or JoVE paper which will be available
soon
also our I think is really important to
reach out to your colleagues a lot of us
are trying to figure this out as we go
and there are some great online forums
like Lyra and comment are both really
helpful to reach out to other people in
the field who are trying to work through
possibly some of the same issues that
you are and might have some really good
advice for you also if you're interested
in seeing the videos that I was not able
to show you today we did in a a last
webinar in 2016 and that is available
online so you can go watch that through
the ALS website as well
and then lastly kind of silly plug
myself but I please contact me at any
time
rabbit social housing is my main
research focus it is my main research
interest I've been doing this for
several years I'm very interested
passion
and learning about it and I'm interested
in all you know facets of it so please
feel free to contact me at any time with
questions I would love to help you
troubleshoot your program in the some of
the ways that we've troubleshooted our
own program oh yeah and we have time for
one more question for our audience
members and I want to remind them that
any question is not answered today will
be answered via email so our final
question is how do I convince others at
my institution that social housing of
rabbits is worth the risk
excuse me thank you that's another great
question um I think the best way to
convince others that social housing
rabbits is worth the risk is to really
make them understand the benefits of
social housing as well as the detriments
of social isolation I think a lot of
times we hear these horror stories about
you know everyone's heard one horror
story about I paired rabbits and they
castrated each other you know some
terrible awful situation so we tend to
think about that and think about how
scary it is instead of really looking
into how beneficial it is for our rabbit
to be housed this way so I think it's
really helpful to show people how much
value that rabbits themselves put on
social housing how good it is for them
and also how detrimental it is when we
singly house them just because we're
scared that they might you know get in a
little fight they're exhibiting serious
signs of stress because of this um
single housing so I think it's really
important to remind people of that as
well and especially to remind them that
some of the physiological effects of
this stress and have a really huge
impact on their research outcomes so
it's really just another layer of how
valuable it is to socially house them
and then to try and get the positive
stories out too I think that's really
helpful since everyone has heard a
negative story about social housing not
as many people for positive stories of
social housing so if you have a good
experience with it tell people about it
share with people what you've learned
what has worked for you that's really
what we try and do is share
work in what hasn't worked for us and I
will say we have been pairing rabbits
males and females for at least four
years now and we average around a yearly
census of about 400 or so rabbits a year
so we have a huge colony out of all of
those that we've paired we've only had
two situations where we've had to
euthanize a rabbit because of social
housing issues and of course you never
ever want to have that situation you
never want to have to euthanize an
animal because of a social housing
situation however when you weigh that
against how many rabbits we've
successfully paired and haven't had
issues with you can see that the
percentage of bad situations are really
minuscule compared to the amount of good
situations so just really try to remind
everybody of that and let them know that
the benefits genuinely do outweigh the
risk sir I want to thank you again for
your presentation today and for your
important research we'd also like to
thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcasts possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know that this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
and thanks for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye-bye